okay hello everyone we are here for a
design review
incremental language development for
wolfram language
we have a variety of topics here
um
are we really ready for this topic
let's should we should we take something
simpler first
yeah we can look at either of the the
other two options as well let's look at
file system tree first
um
oh that's interesting so it's actually
turning it into a
into a tree
yeah so this is sort of the intersection
of the structure that file system map
gives and our trees
um there's a futurized ref page that has
some examples but there are some design
discussions that
ian and i have been having
on and off that uh we need to kind of
sort out
exactly what we want to do with them
okay
all right so basically the idea is is
this runnable or not
uh it's not yet in the prototype builds
okay
okay
all right so if we're gonna say please
don't give a mathematica example let's
do it from one example please
yep we can do that
uh okay
by the way why are the dot files do we
have an option in file system map and so
on to not include hidden files
i see it's right there there's an option
hidden files
details
we should
i think it should be called include
hidden files true or false
hidden files just seems you know
hidden it's true it's unclear if they're
hidden or if they're shown
right
can we can we do that like include
directories include hidden files
is who's who's who's here representing
file system scan file system
that'd be me so yeah we can do that we
have a file name forms option that is
what exists uh in file system map that
we could have a fine but why don't we do
include hidden files
and i would suspect that that should be
false by default
yeah i mean the the question there is
how
you know we want to generalize that out
to other
functions that return files um i don't
think file names currently has
i think that would be a good thing to
have
yes very good thing to do but i think
this is a more extreme case because
we're
i don't know i mean this this case just
seems like i think include hidden files
should be an option to all of these file
you know file directory scanning things
okay yeah by the way i mean how would it
presumably right now it includes them so
i think it would be it would probably be
a bad idea to to
uh make it default to false
yeah you might be right
is
is by the way is that fake output or do
you just have a very bizarre layout
because i don't know right there's no
system files there's no documentation
in
yeah
like i built this and then ran all this
code
i think those are the there's the files
not the directories
yeah it's a single level deep oh
it doesn't show a directory
as a
leaf here which i think is probably
wrong
like include directories i see false
well
otherwise there's always ambiguity
yeah there's like an ambigu
i i think it's good that that you can
know if it's a leaf then there's a file
there
fair enough but what does include
directories to true mean
so the analog that exists in file system
map is that we have an include
directories option in file system map
because there are some functions you may
want to apply to directories and
okay as well as files so what do you
have in mind for file system tree why
not the same thing i mean that is
whether to include in the tree
directories
well as leaves i mean elsewhere how
could you not include them in the tree
can you open this section in the agenda
i i have to say also that it's i find it
very weird that fellow system tree
apparently defaults to level one instead
of infinity
like the windows tree function right the
gives you the full
tree hierarchy
it's basically find the dot for those of
you who are versed in unix command line
uh well the only problem is that that
fine dot gives you sequential output
right it doesn't it doesn't just sure
but morally it's giving right it's
traversing the whole tree whereas this
is basically giving you ls
yeah i understand right i mean a file
system map i think it makes sense for it
to be level one if nothing else because
map is generally level one but i agree i
mean for tree it seems it seems like
it's more important for it to return the
whole tree than for it to be consistent
with file system map i agree
but the only problem is that it could go
very very deep
well if you have a lot of files then you
know
such as the the tree will be very big
yes
but i mean file names comma infinity
would also be very big
yep
um okay let's
let's take it from the top where should
we start looking at this design
so
the root has no data
why the heck does the root have no data
what that's what so
currently i'm saying file system tree
uses the directory you give as the data
which is different from file system map
which just returns an association
okay hold on file system map on a on a
top level directory
just gives the first level doesn't say
the name of the top level directory it
just gives the files in the top level
directory correct correct
okay
so the difference here is that there's
an anchor that is the name of the
directory
which you wouldn't give
in file system map
because
like like map wouldn't give the head of
the function
well that doesn't make it well i think
it's just that map map is returning file
system app returns
like an association yes as opposed to
this which returns a tree the equivalent
thing for this would be if it returned a
forest but we don't support those
right
what does forest mean in this context
i see
question are we is there a forest
i was going to say is there a forestry
plan
never mind um you know is there a
uh i think lists of trees suffice
okay
but then if this did i yeah i i agree
and i think that if this returned a list
of trees that would be goofy yes i agree
therefore i think the right answer is it
probably does want to go from the root
that includes okay so let me just
understand what the structure is here
so
in this tree the data the payload
is always the name of the file or
directory
at that
at that
you know at that position
with the exception of the route
yeah why is that with the exception of
the root that's the direction the root
is not the file name it's the file path
uh it's basically the input absolute
file name of file name well it's just
if you give a relative path there'd be a
relative path there
the alternative is that example the
alternative two
which i think is funky
right i mean that way every every
node
you know is an actual
directory or a leaf you know but
okay so weird
okay let's see the absolute path or you
could convert everything to an absolute
path for the root
so by the way actually just
in these in the tree objects like is the
data i don't know the terminology here
is the data like the payload of the tree
object is it just a string or is it any
expression
what was that a general tree it's any
expression oh yeah but i mean in this in
this one here i mean
all the file names yeah it's just a
string or something or
okay well i guess
the symbol all
but we'll get to that
okay
okay sure okay but i guess the question
is though is i'm just wondering if maybe
it'll be useful
to either put some other stuff in there
or make it possible to get other stuff
because i mean i can imagine things
where as you're going through the tree
you want the full file path not just the
file name in order to get that you'd
have to sort of be keeping track of
where you are like
but but maybe we have exactly that
option in files file systems map
we have exactly that option whether to
give the full file name
right in the in the association correct
guys
oh for god's sake let's not use a
windows machine here for this why are we
doing this why are we doing this
please let's not do that it's just
really confusing
okay
can somebody fix that please
yeah i will take care of that
it should not have happened that way
okay
okay but in any case we've got this
different
i don't even know what the hell is doing
i mean isn't there a way isn't there an
option
to give the full file name i think what
it is is that the full file path
is used for the leaves
in
file system app you apply the function
to the full file path
but the inner nodes are just file names
no that's not correct in this stupid
case with a stupid stupid backslashes
which make it super hard to understand
really hard to understand there's a very
anemic collection of examples here that
really should be improved
okay in any case
there is an option here is there not
there's a fourth argument
that specifies the level of flattening
effectively
so down to level n yup
okay
gives a nested association with our
levels so if that our levels is one
then we get the final path yeah then you
get the file path as the
specification here right that's the key
for the association really advise me
that this is these are really dumb file
names please please use something
doesn't have underscores or other stupid
confusions in it
fair
yeah i think the the original
rationale for this was to use things
that were in the installation directory
because they would be consistent but
yeah they're not good yeah and how about
you don't use the mathematica one please
and can you make sure that other
other examples are checked for the same
thing yep i will
run through our files examples
okay so by the way is there a tree
function
that's sort of like
like tree map but where it tells you
at each step what the path to the root
is
i i think that would essentially be tree
map indexed
well kind of i'm thinking of something
like
i'm thinking of
yeah i i was thinking more of something
where you get the content of all the
nodes back up not just the path right
because that would be sort of the case
of like as you're mapping over like the
question in this case is could you map
over the tree and then be given the path
all the way back up and then just call
file name join on that path and then
it's like equivalent to mapping over the
you know with the file pads the full
file patterns and the content
we don't have that operation but but i
know what you're uh referring to
okay so you're saying
payloading at the roots and going down
each
like branch with a payload at each at
each branch
yeah i mean i'm wondering it might be
i'm looking at the documentation for
tree map as well like if you go into the
details i mean it has
these these different lms but i i'm not
sure if it's easy to get that from one
of these lms
but yeah
um not currently
it would need to be extended
this here
okay so that's an interesting suggestion
right but let's come back to
uh
file system tree
um
okay so
again the objective here and this will
get be more and more interesting as we
have a lighted trees
which hopefully we're going to get
am i making sense
yeah we're planning a function treetop
and it just gives the top
in levels
yeah i understand i mean there's a
question here
of a
lazy alighted tree
that is you go down a certain number of
levels and you when you press a button
so to speak it will open more stuff and
go so
john has a proposal about that
in for the tree outline meeting which i
guess there was some reason why it
couldn't be scheduled last week but that
was
already on the agenda
okay and how does that relate to this
the files so
well
i mean that is uh
john's proposal is sort of a more
general version
i guess the way to of uh right it's not
just for file systems it's right anytime
no i understand i understand but i'm
asking how does that relate to the
design we're trying to do today here
right so i guess the the
right this is the non-late this is the
eager version it goes and sucks
okay but the question is is the other
one an overlay that can be added to any
tree-like structure
i'm asking or are we going to redo the
design twice for this
do you understand my question
uh well it can be used to generate trees
from any sort of generator function i
hit that's not answering my question all
right
i mean that the point that i'm making is
we shouldn't be doing this design if in
fact we are going to be primarily
interested in the dynamic version of
this when we don't know how the dynamic
tree stuff is going to work
i'm making sense
let's do one more pass of this but then
i suspect we we
okay so
the first issue is how to handle the
route
i'm not a big fan of having this thing
that has a very different structure at
the root
i don't quite understand why we're not
giving
just the directory name of the route
and somehow we give the alternative to
well but but without this proboscis here
where do you want to start you want to
start at mathematica
or at layout
i wanted to start at the place where you
said
okay so somewhere that's what this is
you said slash mathematica slash layout
right the dollar installation directory
is an absolute what was the input what
was the input slash mathematica layout
okay then it should probably be this one
no no no but hold on to two points about
why that's a bad
yeah i think so first is is uh is that
this directory that you happen to give
it is very close to the you know the
root of your file system if you give it
something in you know i don't know it's
in documents slash mathematica project
slash whatever it's going to be like
seven layers deep and you're gonna have
seven
things in the tree and also if you want
to say tree map over this or or i don't
know if you want to
like if you're actually doing operations
on this tree you need to know basically
okay how many levels of junk do i have
to go down before i get to the real
content
all right and also the level spec the
level spec that you give this about how
deep to go is going to be relative to
the real content point not the actual
depth of the tree
yeah i agree with that i mean it right
right the point i mean i think part of
the issue here is that he used an
absolute file name right presumably if
if you did file system tree of dot dot
then you would see dot dot in that note
which admittedly is different but it's
easily relatable to the input that was
given
i'm not sure why that makes sense i mean
i'm beginning to think that this
alternative is actually the better
alternative
like file system map
i mean maybe we have a way of getting
the whole thing but but maybe that's
where you start right well but then you
have no way of knowing where this tree
is rooted
that's correct
because you asked for the tree and what
you got was the tree so think about the
following thing people have a piece of
code that's running on different
people's computers
where they're you know where the full
root file you know the full routing of
that file system tree is completely
different on different people's
computers
and they don't really want to see all
that stuff they just want to see from
the place where i cared on down
you know somebody has installed some big
structure they want to see the thing
from the installation point on down
remember making sense well right except
if if you compare with say what find
does right
find the uses whatever you give it right
so find dot will give you dots i know i
know but this isn't the same thing as
find it has different use
cases mean find is showing you
find allows you to manipulate the the
things right you can execute commands on
the things you get all right but but
what do we think
file system tree is going to be used for
other than to admire the tree
and for example being able to get the
file system tree without all the stupid
names of things would be very useful
just the structure of the tree we're
making sense and hopefully we're going
to have some easy functions to do that
right
and you could probably just do a tree
map of null ampersand no no i understand
but i'm just checking with ian that the
thing that i've you know this whole
business about showing a tree without
its labels right vertex labels our own
none basically yes
is that already here or what's happening
with that
i haven't started writing the code for
it okay i consider that a very important
thing and i want to make sure it's in 13
1. it will be
okay
maybe a more general thing though which
would be nice for graph by the way 2
would be something kind of like a vertex
label function that like maybe vertex
shape function or something although i
haven't really used that option much
because
i don't know i imagine there are cases
like this where for the payload of the
tree you'd actually like to have an
association with several things in it
but but but where you know you don't
really want to do that because it'll
make the tree look ugly
yes that's a reasonable point
i think two things we want are we want
the function versions
but we also want x path style
specifications
and either of those solve the the
problem that you have often of like
every a i want it to be this color
but having a function is overkill for
that you'd really want to just have a
simple syntax for saying every a should
be this color
sure but we have that in in graphs you
know how that works right you can just
specify
for vertex styling to specify a pattern
right but it's for vertex names and
vertex names are all unique and that's
not the problem that you're trying to
solve for tree where you have
data that can be duplicated in multiple
places and you're trying to specify the
style based on that
i don't think there's an analog of that
in graph no there isn't but why not use
similarly a pattern type thing maybe
that's what you're proposing to do well
i think that the issue is well i i don't
know i think it would be good to have
some to have a function like a bit of
like a vertex shape function but you
give it both you could give it the yeah
i think we'll have function versions of
every option
if there's a like tree element shape
there will be a trailer what
christopher's gonna say is that you
should be able to give it the location
on the tree exactly yeah i mean that's
like the hash two or something yeah yes
that right ian is that what you have in
mind
which is similar to but i have in mind
something related to like our meta map
where you can specify um
what you want to have put into the
function
okay so
okay i'm still what what's the use case
that you can see for file system tree
other than admiring the tree
i've only ever used the tree command on
on the terminal just for admiring the
tree personally so i don't know
okay
well that's already useful
um
i mean
go ahead
i was thinking that something that i
would want to do is to compare to
subdirectories
to trees
yes what tree comparison functions do we
have right now
we would need something like map thread
i think probably
well all we need something analogous to
uh sequence analysis you know the the
the um
oh gosh what is that called the the
tree is
yes tree alignment
are there real tree alignment algorithms
though and i guess the pattern matcher
is kind of like a tree alignment it's
very related algorithm like
unification of patterns
yeah
well but but i mean
no i but i think about our pattern match
up which matches trees
is there a way of of
matching
a an expression against
no you have to turn it back into
an expression probably to match it
as opposed to uh never mind well you
might be able to take a pattern and then
use the tree object you know
you use sort of the make a pattern for
expression trees
but yeah
couldn't you do it as a sequence
alignment type problem where you flatten
the tree using one of the standard like
infix forms or
you know polish notation or whatever
yes
probably i mean and then do sequence
alignment on it
right i think it's an interesting class
of functions which could be prototyped
in wfr to actually look at
essentially tree diffs
okay
but okay maybe we should go back to meta
maps since you've referred to that
um
okay
is is this a proposal somewhere so well
i have a proposal only for trees uh if
you want to open that page tree meta
applied
the right i haven't thought about how
this
relates more broadly
it's an exotic name
and there's fake examples on here
okay so this is the thing
within tree map
that lets you get information about
okay so this would normally be
a function there but this could be an
operator form of this that says tree
matter apply to position
open bracket f
close bracket is that correct
i think that if we have this
whatever we call it wrapper around the
function it it can't just work by
applying that function to things it has
to be like understood by
the surrounding function
as a rapper
no i i understand i mean no
yes either either i guess i'm saying
either way works because tree map is
just going to have to check to see if
there's a tree applied there
fine
yeah there's no syntactic reason why we
couldn't have it as a
as a
thing wrapping the whole expression as
opposed to
yeah an operator form for the f
as opposed
right okay
okay so now what you're saying is
what to actually feed in
i mean this could be in tree map
couldn't it
this information about what to feed in
so we started doing this with tree map
attaching it to the level spec so you
see you have level spec arrow subtree
level spec arrow sub original sub tree
okay but you're saying this this is a
thing that lets you
you know give an additional argument
or give a sequence of arguments that you
specify
i mean additional argument to the this
is saying
instead of putting it in the level spec
you are telling it
to what you want that function to apply
by default it's just going to apply to
probably what you're calling data
and in principle i could give a list of
things there and it would apply to that
whole
exactly it would apply as the hash one
hash two to that sequence
i think i have an example further down
what was the reason again why or was
there a reason why i couldn't just uh
you know if you write hash position
whatever
inside your function it can't just look
at the function you gave it look at what
keys you used and then
and then you don't need this wrapper at
all
oh i guess there was the issue of when
the data
you know if there is sort of a generic a
cash one case if that hash one case it
could be an association
what could be an association well i'm
just remembering one of the ideas we had
for this to avoid having the rapper was
to have it so that
you know
say if you if you have map indexed you
can either use your hash one hash two or
if you just ask for hash position
yeah i get it yeah but the issue is that
if you're doing map indexed
one might be an association in which
case hash position
is a meaningful thing
yes but there are even worse issues
right because there's also the question
of
uh you know if you can't put a hash
there because you have to have an
explicitly named function variable
because of uh you know other code
outside because of a hash collision
so to speak a different meaning of hash
collision but you understand what i mean
but you've got two nested functions and
they're both using hash
you can't disambiguate that yeah sure
sure yeah that's true
the
i'm just i'm just a little bit well
yeah i mean if
if nothing else i think that the the
name of this thing has to be better and
shorter
but yeah then tree matter applied for
sure
right i mean i mean i'm just
yeah i'm just worried that it's going to
be kind of verbose
my gut tells me if the if
the arguments were given in an
association and you used
like
like slot position that that would make
things more verbose
and no no no no add boilerplate to
extract values if you want to do pattern
matching
right i i think that this general
approach
which might just be a general
meta-applied function
uh
or with meta
or something no it's meta applied is
really the right thing
um
are we really going i thought i thought
meta was kind of a placeholder name is
meta the actual name of this thing
it's got metadata so it's not completely
crazy
oh that's why okay i didn't even realize
that's why it was called that i thought
i would just call that because meta is
sort of a vaguely amorphous term that
was being used as a placeholder well it
might have been but i but we realized
that it actually is including metadata
um this is actually quite close to curry
applied in the sense of i mean just
using names rather than numbers to
talk about
arguments
right well those are both then i mean
curry applied a meta reply to both
fairly exotic sounding things
um
yeah i feel like i feel like if you're
reading a piece of code you see map
index that's understandable
if you're absolutely going to see meta
applied
that's that's a little harder to justify
well if we can come up with a better
name but i think that the basic idea is
um
i mean those strings by the way
i don't see how we can avoid having
those strings
um
so it's going to say i mean in the case
of tree matter applied there it's only
being fed the position right
yeah maybe
maybe there could be a one argument form
of meta applied that does this this
thing where where you know it it it
looks and
basically it just gives an association
yes right but then if you have the
nested hash case
then you can uh
then then you can you can use this other
syntax
oh well the fake output it looks like
it's being also
being fed to data which is
counter-intuitive to me
no that's wrong
that's cannot be the case
it cannot both have data and position it
because you don't even know which order
it's in and so on
am i making sense
this has to be either
ian
you with us right yeah i had to restart
okay can you hear me yes we can now
okay i'm actually not sure about that so
i mean this is modeled on on map index
or the position applied that we were
discussing which is adding
arguments not remember but it's super
weird that if you have a list position
a subtree whatever that it is the hash
blah plus one that corresponds to each
of those
i mean the question is when you write
this are you basically ninety-nine
percent of the time gonna write meta
applied and then you're gonna write data
comma blah blah blah my idea was that if
you if you just say one thing then it's
applied as an additional argument but if
you give it a list then those are the
arguments that you give in order
so that you have to listen to them
because you overwrite it so it's not
just additional but maybe i don't want
the data
but so if it's a list of posit quotes
position would give you a different
thing from just quotes this deposition
would give only the position as one as
the only argument
right okay
that's not completely crazy
yeah okay
so
so let's see so what are the possible
there's a lot here
that's
huh
lot of interesting stuff
um
maybe ancestors could be added to this
yeah like an ancestor list or something
so how would this relate to map couldn't
map have many of this very exact so
because i mean you know a tree is just
like an expression tree
couldn't map have many of the same
meta options
yeah i think map would have obviously
position
index you'd have expression or
sub-expression
level
so there may be some that are specific
to trees but
yeah i like the idea of having a single
meta function or or decorator headdress
that handles this rather than having a
tree permutation an association
permutation etc
right i mean and then it might support
slightly different
named
things depending on where it appears
right if you're in an association you
may need
keys and values
all right so this is this concept of
matter applied
uh
it's a little bit of a weird name but it
is a slightly um
i mean the alternative by the way
somebody has a bunch of background noise
but but you know it's like a with meta
but that isn't quite the right thing
either it's it's an applied type thing
just like curry applied i
believe this is long though is the only
unfortunate thing
well it will also complete quickly i
don't think we have a lot of other
matters
well it's more about the i'm thinking
more about readability i mean if you
have a long thing there does make it
harder to
to read
yes well we could always have a
formatting form for it
and we always could have a meta applied
is some kind of i mean like like for
example here's a here's a weird example
of a possibility
that um we could have something where we
have i can't really draw it but where
you have um
uh
you know when you have this
then we could have formatting of matter
applied that includes that rights on top
of the arrow position or something like
that
that completely bonkers
i
think that's relatively bonkers
um
in other words that it would say
you've got a function
well i mean right this is assuming you
have a pure function first of all right
i mean you could just give it an f that
knows what to do with the base
um
i mean i could imagine an infix form of
this i could imagine something although
that might make code look even more
obscure but it might be something
and also i mean we just like we just
added support for for you know basically
type setting that
the backslash fn or the escape fn arrow
i mean now you can write that
you know in in outside of mathematica
you can write it in a in a text editor
so i think it's sort of a bit backwards
to then add
another sort of thing on top of that
that you won't be able to write in a
text editor and you have very little
hope of doing so
yeah okay well okay i personally
wouldn't use the function symbol unless
it could be used in plain text
right
well okay in terms of the name whether
you know whether there's a meta fide i
mean if we think this is going to be
really common we could just call it some
kind of meta thing
i mean i don't know what um
no that's really weird
um
i still think the term meta is a little
bit
i mean it just means so many it means so
many different things and and you know
well what else could concluding
including companies that were until
recently called facebook and stuff like
that instead of strange
um
metaverse is a new type of poetry
okay
uh
okay so
well so there's a naming question
although i feel like it is you know with
metadata basically
what else could this be
can i kind of
uh argue that
the tree version should be separate from
the other version
yeah
with trees you have this
additional freedom between have the data
at
a position
and the subtree at the position
and that gives rise to a lot of the
specific things but also
tree meta applied has this third
argument
where
you know
it's not just what arguments are given
to the function but what
thing gets updated and in
in trees right now we're only ever
updating the data
it means we can't update the shape of
the tree with a tree map
and this would allow a tree map to
really
you know do any transformation to a tree
i don't necessarily want to like
uh
we don't have to solve
this for trees but
at that point it's not just applying to
metadata
it's some kind of like how is this
function getting applied input and
output
but that's saying how it re-glues the
result back into the tree is that
correct
yeah that's a completely orthogonal
issue for what the function got fed in
my view i mean would it be would it be
possible to have that as an argument to
like tree map or whatever this gets
eaten by if you know what i mean
like the third argument would be outside
of the meta applied
that makes sense
yeah i i don't believe that should be in
the matter applied
another question just a more basic
question is the theory of meta applied
or whatever that that the keys would be
the same for every function that can eat
it or no they'll be different i think
where they overlap they should be the
same but sometimes there'll be different
kinds of things like the payload versus
whatever else is different yeah okay
fine but so i guess the the point being
that it's not a problem right i mean the
other issue here was just that that it's
going to have three specific keys but
that's fine because that's fine specific
keys yeah because i think there's going
to be
i mean
what are other places here i mean things
like parallel map
could have a meta applied
that contains things like processor name
and so on
that doesn't seem as useful because this
dollar process id stuff well fair enough
okay um well i actually
what would be useful is things to know
like how big big a batch this thing was
part of that kind of stuff things
map that are not known to the cold
process
and um
or even things like progress
what about contextual applied
it's long but it's not well the only
problem is that context
well contextualized of f or something
uh well there's also environment but
there's all the all these words have
such ridiculous
additional baggage
um yeah i was thinking markup but that's
also the wrong direction
um
basically what arguments you are
supplying it's like the handler
functions
it's uh
[Music]
um
i don't know this requires more thought
it's some kind of
contextualized well there's got to be a
better term than
um
environmentalized so to speak that's
really what we're looking for and by the
way there is also the option of just
calling it metadata
i don't think i think that's weird
because it's a function
you know it's a whole function story and
so on
um
uh
well if we are going to remove the
applied
perhaps something similar like extended
yeah
possibly um
of just the word applied by itself
we also apply and what map
applier map applied element applied
that seems obscure property applied
where am i splitting this ld
okay so what are our possible names here
we've got
matter applied
we've got um contextualized
oh it's often going to look like this
i mean that's pretty obscure i have to
admit
neta applied position of f is pretty
obscure
oh is that the is the syntax that or is
it position the first argument or is
position last argument well i think it's
this or it's
meta applied
of f comma position
i mean it could also be meta applied of
quotes position comma f
which is a bit which is actually has a
bit of an analogy to the syntax for for
function
like as in pure functions like those the
arguments yep
yeah that's a good point and the
list versus not list
well so what about the possibility of
decorating function in some way
is that obviously completely crazy like
for example like the fourth argument
no no i was thinking of something like
this but this is obviously this is
perhaps crazy
yes
um i mean it's not it's the only
like
it's not obviously
crazy
i mean it's a bit long but then the
issue is that if you if you just have an
f it doesn't work and if you want to
write with hash it doesn't work either
right
i mean unless unless we did something we
could do something for the hash case of
if you just don't specify the x and y
then just as a function of one argument
well it's not ambiguous because you
can't have strings you can't have
strings there but but it's it's weird
right and it will lead
bugs in the world
will be something like this comma
one plus two
that's crazy that's wrong wait a minute
what do you even do with function what
do you do with hashes inside function
uh they they turn green when it's one
argument i mean here it's just
right
okay but that looks a little crazy
it does look a little crazy
but but this is conceptually what's
happening it's bringing in additional
okay so what we've
got well really it's it's if anything
it's
i mean i hate to say it's a little bit
like typed
because it's like typed it's saying okay
this is the name of the variable and
this is what i expect to be passed into
this argument yes
is telling you what the type is going to
be this is a bit higher level
well typed is characterizing what x
could be
as opposed to where x gets itself value
from well no but this is the same
signature applied
that sounds like digital signatures like
the type signature
but the thing is it's not a type right i
mean it's in the same way though that
typed is basically telling you
i want you to give me an integer into
this argument this is this is also the
function telling you what it wants you
to feed into its arguments
yes that's true but but but i i mean i i
mentioned this but i also think that i i
can't imagine there's a reasonable
syntax that can come from this analogy
right and i mean
i would think that uh
you know if we uh go to the trouble of
extending the syntax of function we'd
want it
something more general like you know
supporting patterns or something as
opposed to this very specific case
about if you want something short
without fed
thinking
dead like as in
wait okay
yes
not like the federal reserve
right not like the federal reserve
fare that's in your pets
feed
i mean it is what people say
feed in position yeah yeah
what about vp
[Music]
so i think i think uh
you know to to list the complaints right
so i think feed sounds like rss feed
which might be fine um include
sounds like me or like uh like too many
you know
in c yeah
uh
with is already taken
yep
what about using
using also sound to conclude too many
languages you're using include whereas
it's like means
yeah except that you can you'll be able
to see that it's that it's saying using
position
that's not crazy i'm thinking more of a
writing perspective than a reading
perspective in the sense that someone is
going to write using instead of writing
needs and just be confused but yeah
but no it's not too bad but what is
using already it's black
apparently used by roots
it's an option
it's not documented
if you look at that's ancient
it's for nested roots and it's
absolutely ancient
um it could be changed i'm pretty sure
because it's uh
strictly internal
yeah it's not that's one of those i like
the mentality toward using it i i mean i
love these like you know version two
symbols that are taken where it's like
oh yeah you know this common english
word version one
no it really shouldn't be um and it
probably could even be stringified or
put in an internal context as some other
name
okay using is interesting in my view
i mean so what it would look like is map
using
position
of or using index for example of that
would be map index basically
index would be just the number and
position would be like map indexed
exactly so this is in fact the
that that's the thing you often want the
map so i'm saying that would not give
you map index i i'm you're correct it
will be this one which gives you map
indexed
but it's unfortunate that
what it's unfortunate that we can't be
you know it would be nice if if if it
was called you know mapped position or
something like that because in that way
we could have positions or like extract
style and indices are like the numbers
but we've been consistent
we can add the possible issues
map index should have been called map
map positions
well we can also have a function for map
positions going forward
yeah the problem is we can't change map
index so that doesn't really make it you
know doesn't really help anything but
can you write these using examples using
a comma instead of the bracket that the
like very curried
you know
what what which order do you want to put
it try both
yeah okay all right so then
um
okay so you're saying something
we have something similar with carry
applied in which is f comma
n
yes which is just like this exactly
and we when we use carrying we typically
carry the second argument not the first
so so the argument for having the the
quotes be at the beginning is for you
know because realistically f is going to
be long
and so if you have the
the thing that says position at the
beginning
honestly i think it's it's a bit more
readable because it it's a bit closer to
writing map indexed where you get to see
what's being
you know fed to the function right on
the other hand the other argument would
be if you want to do that use the
courage form
yeah
i just think the curried form is a
little bit obscure looking
like it's easy to you know especially
for like for because this is such a
basic you know if the idea is that
basically this is what you should use
instead of map indexed in the future
i don't know like i you know explaining
to a beginning mathematica programmer
like oh you know this is the syntax you
know it's so much more complicated than
map indexed right now
yeah that's pretty obscure that but this
would be okay so you're saying
using index
f
another thing to know would be if f is a
function you know it's written by like
saying function open bracket blah blah
blah then the things like position and
so on will be right next to where the
argument names are specified
yeah but i still think if you want it
first use the current form if you want
second i mean
using index
i argue that the curried form curried
forms are for when you have a function
that you'd like to for example map oh
you know you'd like to map over things
you'd like to select over things etc i
think curried forms are not really for
we want a version of this function where
its arguments go the other way around
because i can see no scenario where you
actually use
using of quotes position in like a
functional way like feeding into map or
something like that
um take for example a case in which you
know you are going to be using this with
lots of functions and you want to define
a symbol
in equals using index and then you just
use int f in g in whatever
where where ins means it's in you know
the indexed version
yes so it would just be that
and
you'd hope you'd hope that you know
whatever syntax we have is short enough
that you don't need to make a shorthand
like that right
no i'm just trying to point out a case
in which you would use a current form
this was at the same discussion we had
with carrie
and and and it was one of the reasons
why we have separate carry applied and
operator applied just to allow this
incurred
and carry applied
to allow curry applied of one
curry applied of two of f
[Music]
um
f
x y
yeah right but i feel like in this case
isn't it
well
but is there ever a situation where
you're going to for example be mapping
your curry applied
over something or you're going to be
selecting something by curry applied or
if you get what i mean yes i think so
curry applied
well without the f just curry applied of
two
oh that's pretty obscure
and the other the other thing is that i
would argue that curry applied
i think the the tolerance for having
weird curried bracket
bracket wizardry stuff
is the tolerance that's much higher with
curry applied because this function's
whole purpose is to enable crazy bracket
wizardry stuff
right you know you're better i'm just
thinking people start you know beginning
beginning mathematica programmers
struggle enough with like where does
where's the closed bracket go let alone
if you have some triple curried thing
every time you want to use map indexed
okay i feel like using of index comma f
might be confusing because there the
index is in the first argument but it's
getting passed to the as the second
argument to f
that's a very crazy weird thing because
obviously you're using an f comma index
like
nothing is changing orders
well i that i that's a weird argument
but i i have to say i tend to think
look we could have an alternative
we could have alternatives for this
that involve being able to put
this stuff into level specs and so on we
could have multiple syntaxes just like
slash at is a you know alternative
syntax for map well okay but i i think
the thing is i think it's
i i i think it's it's fine you know with
the positions in either the first or
second argument of using the thing i
oppose just the idea of like we're gonna
have two sentences and taxes
where it's not really clear which is the
preferred one and and you know
both of them work and we're just kind of
leaving up to users to say like which
one is more readable wait wait of which
and which of currying and non-currying
or what yeah
like i think supporting both of those is
a little bit pointless because it
because the curried one that the only
purpose that the curried one serves is
to let you put the arguments in the
reverse order right that's the only
reason we've thought of for why
okay but you could argue that at sign
and slash slash are also why do we need
those well it's no because they're
shorter well they could but they but
they always make your code look better
you should always use those and you
should never use you should only use the
explicit forms if you need to give a
level spec or something like that the
point is with this there is no you know
what is the decision tree for how you
decide which syntax you're going to use
and if the answer is just like oh it's
based on your personal preference on
which one is more readable
then this is kind of like well we should
just tell them what's the more readable
one
okay
fair point but i'm not convinced here
but but but let's
i do like your argument about this being
long and it being very obscure what what
you are looking for if this goes second
on the other hand the argument that
curry applied has that second
i don't know i mean i can see the
argument that it reads nicely if you say
using index f
i mean i think by the way having using f
index is also pretty much fine i i just
think having both doesn't work
both what
both directions by having the curried
pack
like either either the string goes first
or second and and saying it goes second
but there's a create form so that you
can put it first
and we're not going to tell you how you
decide which one to use
i think that that's what i don't like
well but so
all right
um
note the vast majority of our
current operators carry the second
argument so they do this flip okay but
i'll give you an argument for this way
round
if you're writing this code
there's a very high probability you know
you want to use the index before you
start writing the f
so it's natural to put that first
um
okay
i i also think it's just um easier i
mean i guess i'm repeating christopher
here but i just think it's easier to
read right you see what what what you're
going to be using and then you can
interpret any explicit hashes in the
in the article
that's a good point that the hashes are
otherwise uninterpretable until you get
to the end okay well so provisionally
this looks like a reasonable syntax
um
then our live stream mentions um
uh with metadata
which yes that that is a
uh i mean i don't think
i think using maybe better but i think
um
and using is much better than meta
matter is just obscure
says the person who's about to put out
this tome about metamathematics which is
obscure from the beginning
um
okay so what do we want to discuss about
this so you but so we have shot down the
idea that we need a separate tree meta
applied
is that a true statement
so well different functions that support
using
like in their notes section they'll have
to say
what things you can use inside the using
exactly just like they do for many other
kinds of um
options like from
i don't know you know um
color functions to many other things
but you have discussed a different thing
which is the re-gluing of trees
yeah i'll explore if the re-gluing can
just be specified in the function
okay instead of having it in this
okay
and let's think about where using could
also be used so to speak
i mean this seems like a good general
construct
it's like one could use it in
for example how would it work in things
like nearest
it will be an alternative to the
syntax that we have right now
well nearest the syntax if you're
thinking of the arrow syntax that
determines what's returned not what's
passed into any function
oh i see but what this could be used for
is these things where we have
uh
well actually this color function stuff
and those kinds of things could use this
in principle
right well you have a think about that
the way where you're giving one two
three four
or alternatively something
all these various things where they have
a comparison function where we have
these other kinds of functions
particularly ones where we have multiple
arguments
you know we could name those arguments
and we can allow people
okay so the question is what's the
relationship between okay so look
the
there might also be the possibility of
something like using all
and then this f
would become an association you know
would be fed an association
etc and all would again depend on the
function right it would depend on the
function but then the whole point is
that then in the f there you'll be able
to say using all
and then this was also the proposed
thing about having a single argument
version of it
so using of f would be
i think maybe that's interesting using
the the name using a little bit weird
with that but using of f would just
would be effectively that and then maybe
it could even be optimized so that
it looks so fun to look at the function
yeah that's interesting
yeah so
i'm using this no hopeless for that case
yeah
um
but i do like the possibility of having
a one argument wrapper and that would
shoot down my
uh currying
because i think this is significantly
more useful than the curried case
uh i mean this is a case where the whole
metadata thing
um
what could this be
um
honestly i have to imagine that that the
single i mean if the single argument
form can be done
you know that's the only thing you'll
ever use
i mean it's it's like it's like that the
the multi-argument one will only ever be
useful basically for nested pure
functions or something
or say you just want to use f in your
code and then define f using down values
and not have it
be something that takes an association
sure sure but i mean
yeah but i mean most of the time
if you're writing a function yourself
and you're
and you're mapping it or something like
that and you get to design how the
arguments look you're just writing a
pure function so
yeah i mean i think this is not an
unreasonable thing to want to do
okay so one question would be could we
define a function
which essentially expects to
dyslexically
um
i mean i mean this is the zero thing is
just
you know it could just pass in an
association that would work i mean i
don't know if there's performance
problems with it
and that was one of the things that's
one of the things
you have to form the the i think the
point is that you want to analyze and
know which keys you need like
if you
don't want the negative level then you
don't want to have to do a depth first
traversal just to get it
yeah that's good exactly right and and
also but but even more generally
something like yes the for the tree
example that's that's a good one but
even more for just like map indexed if
if you run map index and it has to
construct an association even if it's
just an association of the index and the
the value for every iteration that's
going to have a huge performance impact
right so you don't want to be able to
have to do it but the question is can we
give a name
where it is a reasonable thing to
lexically scan the code
and clearly with is known to be a
lexical scanning function well but i
mean the point is is that i don't think
you don't need to know that it's
lexically scanning it because it'll be
the the
behavior will be absolutely identical
right
why why i don't understand if the thing
is going to be passing
oh i guess i guess there could be
certain
no because if you don't have f
what
yeah if you have f
then i mean but
yeah but then it can see that you have a
hash and not a hash position right
oh i see what you're saying and of
course it's not hold first so it's not
like so whatever the function is right
and if you can connect the function
okay if you're constructing a function
or the piece of if there's a piece of
code that returns the pure function
it'll have evaluated by the time you're
doing this
okay what about clashing
colliding hashes
like if there's a nested
you know
if inside of the using there's another
using in some next way
is that what well i we have to think
through what that case is
i think it's a much simpler case right i
mean if you have
um
something hash plus
no your point is that within the using
you have
yeah yeah right i mean this is the case
but that case is kind of crazy i mean
within the using with
right we're trying to access the
external hash
right you can also have cases where
i i bet you can have cases where it's
pretty hard to tell is this hash
position from this using or is it from
this using and what key was included in
this using and stuff like that but but
honestly i i i think
you know given that this is just sort of
behind the scenes invisible optimization
you know worst case it computes a little
bit too much
right and
it was still no i don't know but why
doesn't it refer to the wrong hash
in the case i mean this is just a
problem of nested pure functions right
well right i mean
right this one will do nothing right i
mean if you use this map
the the inner pound or sorry the outer
pound the one to the left of the plus
will be fed the values of the thing and
the using will just sit there inert
because
those are
not pure
pure variables of the outer ampersand no
i understand
but
okay so your claim is you will never
need a
named version
you can always use no i think there will
be a version in some cases but but but
it'll be you know and like like ian said
i mean if you want to pass it f you know
defined with down values then you need
to have a named case
but um
okay so what about the possibility of
messing with the function function
in the named case
what about if the if most of the aligned
form is done with a wrapper and then um
uh
well
right but see see i don't i don't think
that pound thing can work the using of
just pound right you'd have to use pound
position and pound data and whatever
right because pound would be referring
to like the whole association yes yeah
exactly exactly yeah
[Music]
yes
okay so
i think we need a name for this case
this is a nice case
i agree i think that this is um
uh
i think there's two cases that you might
want all are automatic like all is uh
the association of everything that could
be computed and automatic is lexically
scan this pure function
and
only compute the things that show up in
the slots
right or you can explicitly say what to
compute
that's what you're saying is the
that's like if you use slot position
then it has to compute it
no i understand but if if um
uh okay but but the question okay so
then what do we need here we need
a
a rapper
see i'm worried that people will forget
the wrapper unless we name it very
carefully
so they just think they can type slot
position
in a map
and a function to be used in the map
um
well i mean we can clearly have some
code assistance things i mean clearly
what we could do there
if it can tell
that it is making a function that is
only to be used in the map that is it
has an ampersand closing it off inside
the map it could turn it red in the case
we don't have a using around it
could it not what if you're mapping on
something that has
that key in it
then you're that's a false negative yeah
okay okay okay that's not gonna work
right so we have to have some way
okay all right we should wrap up in a
moment here but but um
well i like the general concept of this
i think it requires more thought
um
okay
and with respect to our
um file system tree
i think we need some more use cases
i mean for example do you expect to do
tree map of file system tree
i don't know
well but i mean that's a that's an
example of something file system map is
essentially
would be that but only on the leaves
whereas doing a tree map would allow you
to map on internodes
i certainly would like to do that with
um
with sizes so knowing the distribution
of sizes and how they are splitting
yes would be very useful
well so then that's a good case where
you might want to display
okay where you say the nodes might be
a name and a size or something
but where you might want to display i
don't know what you would do i mean and
also
lighting the names do we have an easy
way because the names might get really
long do we have an easy way to specify
that and this is part of the um you know
vertex display function thing
to specify that you want to only show
the first 10 characters of the name or
some such other thing
right so we should have a mechanism for
that because that's that's going to come
up quite a lot
i'm making sense
do you understand
ian
i kind of think that the more pressing
issue is that the layout currently
doesn't take anything any kind of
information about the size into account
you know so you can end up with trees
with lots of white space or with weird
collisions
no no we're talking about actual file
sizes
what are we what are you talking about
sorry we're talking about you're talking
about the way it like you're talking
about visualization of the file system
tree
yes and we're talking about and what
jose was saying is that he would like to
know the size of each file
going down the the hierarchy of files
directories and files and so on okay and
then what i was saying was okay but if
you display that and you have a very
long file name it's going to mess up the
actual display of the tree
so what i was then saying was the name
of the file if it's 30 50 characters
long
should be eight characters and then dot
dot dot
that's all i was saying and so then i
was saying what is our mechanism for
eliding doing a short for example on
every uh
you know that was the thing you were
talking about vertex
um
like the vertex label function goes to
short
yeah for example yes exactly
that's exactly what we're talking about
there
and having an easy way to do that
because you know vertex label function
goes to none
which is a bit like vertex labels
actually none it's the wrong thing there
so it's like vertex labels goes to none
it's what i keep on wanting for these
trees
just show me the structure of the tree
making sense
i mean that's the case which for me
is the number one use case for trees
right i don't want to see the content i
just want to know the structure of the
tree
now by the way what's the state of doing
xml trees actually there are two
questions have we thought about how text
structure is going to work with trees
you will be able to do expression tree
of a text element and get a tree
if you open the prototype build you
should be able to do expression tree of
xml
but i think he's talking about something
else
i'm sure about text structure here the
text structure function
yeah that will just be another thing
that's supported by expression tree
what
wait a minute no
no
no no no no i'm talking about if i want
to get out of this
what is it called isn't it called
constituent trees
i mean isn't the full form of that some
nice thing anyway
yeah what if you just say special tree
on it right now
well it'll it'll give you
the underlying expression but it won't
give you this tree
right but that's the point i want to be
able to get this tree out of text
structure
you will literally just do expression
tree of the text structure and you'll
get this tree
wait but then that means expression tree
doesn't always just give you the tree of
the full form it might do intelligence
right which
uh we decided last time we discussed
uh expression tree that expression tree
should be smart and
figure out what kind of tree you gave it
okay but i'm not sure you want to have
to do expression tree here this thing
treat text structure blah comma tree
should just give this freaking tree
as a tree
without you having to wrap the text
structure you know someone's saying
different a different property of text
structure should just give the tree
yeah that makes sense yeah yeah
okay let me see one thing but wait by
the way i mean is that sorry about the
expression tree thing i mean don't we
have like a tree expression i mean are
these things gonna round trip all the
time
certainly if you specify the structure
then it will round trip
well what do you mean if you specify the
structure i mean like i'm just like if
you say comma
text structure
then it'll know
convert this tree into a text element
but there might be an issue with like
automatically detecting from a tree for
tree expression
right i mean if i have some big if i
have some big
you know expression in the middle of it
is a text structure
is it going to
it's going to just unpack it as an
expression
yes
it's
the structure just based off of the
the outer like top level expression
okay i don't know i'm just i'm i'm
slightly i'm slightly
suspicious of
of it but i mean maybe it's i mean it
does seem like there probably are many
cases where it's like we have some
object and we want to turn it into a
tree
so the current behavior always uses a
specific structure and you have to
specify a different structure if that's
what you want
yeah i don't think it's right but we'll
come back to that a different time
because i have to go in a moment here so
so are you going to show me this what do
we do here yeah i say expression tree of
that comma
xml
so the point is that we're losing all
the xml element stuff in there is that
correct
but if i say here
tree expression
you would say tree expression of that
comma xml
okay that's quite nice is that right yes
it is right
can i just look at one realistic these
are really bad
example data
paintings.xml
paintings
yes
like this
um it doesn't default to xml if it sees
an xml element there no not yet
this is not useful again here i mean
we've got to find a way look this tree
needs to have more vertical height
okay what am i supposed to do here
other than just make my window wider
i think what we really want is an
outline view
yes we do our graph view
yes we do
okay well that's nice by the way what
about other i mean i can imagine we
could have other tree layouts like some
sort of radial
thing yeah
there's a tree layout option
putting it to the left
do trial tree layout goes to left
much more useful
what the hell happened there what's that
there
it was empty
no it's not a bug the xml object
document has a preamp i don't know the
official terminology has a preamble and
then the body and then an afterward and
afterward was the empty list
i see
okay
that's not bad
um
cool
all right i should run off here um
okay well this is good this is good i
think we've got some definite uh things
to do next yes
yep
okay sounds good